also das was man in deutschland sieht
dass sich eine ideologie die total
zerrissen aus amerika nach europa
überschwappte sich hier ausbreitet und
ja richtiggehend kulturkämpfe
ausgelöst hat diese
woge kultur ist in sich rassistisch weil
durch diese critical race theorie
menschen in hautfarben
eingestuft werden und ihre wertigkeit
der durch ausgelesen werden also ich als
dunkelhäutiger mensch hier in
deutschland bin eben diskriminierte als
sie es sind und sie sind laut diese
theorie ja auch privilegiert und habe
privilegien die ich niemals bekommen
werden und wer ich werde als migrant
hier auch den ganzen tag nur unterdrückt
die deutsche mehrheitsgesellschaft ist
komplett rassistisch und jeder der meint
dass dieses system anders ist wie ich
das sage wird als rechter oder als nazi
diffamiert und man nutzt diese situation
also die geschichte deutschlands aus und
menschen mundtot zu machen das ist etwas
wo wir aufpassen müssen weil auch unsere
kultur unsere geschichte soll verleugnet
werden es wäre statuen gestürzt es
werden schulbücher geändert sollen filme
abgeschafft werden die angeblich
rassistisch sind also ich höre den
ganzen tag immer wieder dass bestimmte
wörter menschen verletzen würden wo sind
diese verletzten menschen ich würde mich
niemals auf regen als türke wenn jemand
das wort getürkt sagt also wie kommen
wir dazu oder winnetou zum beispiel
sollte abgesetzt werden weil das wort
indiana drin vorkommt die bild zeitung
hat doch bei den indianern nachgefragt
sie sagen doch selber dass sie sich
entweder als american nails oder indien
native bezeichnen und das ist eine
kultur die sich hier durchsetzt und die
köpfe besonders der jungen menschen
vergiftet weil
das soziale leben findet mittlerweile
online statt und dort passieren diese
kultur kriege und wenn man diesen kultur
kriege offline menschen zu bringt das
versteht kein mensch mehr bewegung kommt
ja aus den vierziger jahren übrigens
schon also die gibt es schon ganz lange
und am anfang war ansatz dahinter auch
dass vor allem hat farbige menschen
gekämpft haben für ihre rechte deswegen
ich glaube was sie meinen nennt man wohl
washing es kommt eigentlich nur so vor
ich habe letztens selber recherchiert
weil ich auch immer sage wo und dann
sieht man dass der das dh gegen zwei
viel länger her ist also die disziplin
euro kommt aus den 40er jahren sie haben
aber unrecht ich bin auch nicht
privilegiert weil ich bin eine frau also
ich muss auch die gesellschaft muss auf
mich beschützen für sind normalerweise
frau hatten sie vor dementsprechend bin
ich doch anscheinend privilegiert schon
mal gut aber daheim wenn sie sind ja
eigentlich der typische nicht
schützenswerte also typische nicht
schützenswerte individuum sie sind ein
mann sie sind hellhäutig und ich glaube
heterosexuelle damit sind sie überhaupt
nicht schützenswert wie sehen sie das
denn wenn jemand sagt also ich fühle
mich davon eigentlich diskriminiert also
ich finde diese sprach potenzial
veranstaltung auch vollständig absurd
ich habe nicht den eindruck wie sie dass
sie ich habe hier vier kinder dass man
das ist ein sehr kleines thema da
in der tat gibt es gruppen diesem
diskriminiert worden zuallererst
natürlich die homosexuellen mehr
strafrechtlich verfolgt das sind und was
gott der diskriminierung damit müssen
uns natürlich auseinandersetzen wenn das
aber nicht mit sprachgebrauch
unterstellen ich bin ich rate nur auch
umgekehrt zu gelassenheit wenn jemand zu
ändern will soll er denn dann ist
also das ist durchaus ein thema wo wir
aufpassen müssen mal es geht um
freiheitsbeschränkungen es geht um die
frage was darf ich eigentlich sagen darf
ich mir rastalocken machen also es sind
ja ist ja wie heißt das die motoren im
haus einladen
obwohl sie eigentlich durchaus er
irgendwie
für eine bunte gesellschaft eintritt und
auch so ein festival sehen wollte
kultureller aneignung ist also auch ein
ganz großes verbrechen aber wie sie
schon sagten mit winnetou ich meine
diese ganzen bücher atmen eigentlich ein
geist von von zwar lief aber irgendwie
menschenfreundlichkeit und zwar egal wer
da
ist aus das ist tatsächlich und es nur
auf die leichte schulter zu nehmen und
sich darüber lustig zu machen wie man
das mit dem mit diesem jahr
verstolperten
bürgerinnen immer macht der oder
irgendwie professorinnen immer irgendwie
so also ich finde das ist eine ganz
schöne entwicklung grammatikalisch
gesehen aber es ist viel mehr es geht
eher um macht es geht um verteilung von
chancen also jetzt die union ist ja auch
umgeknickt und darüber die cdu und hat
eine frauenquote meinte als
gerechtigkeit instrument ich sehe das
nicht so ich finde das ist wieder ein 1
1 ordnen in schubladen der als nächstes
über leoni ohne die sich das gewünscht
haben ja aber das ist ein viertel der
mitglieder und sie kriegen die hälfte
der posten also ich finde das ist keine
gerechtigkeit bei der union bei bei den
grünen wird immer gesagt man ist
fortschrittlich wenn dann fast alle
posten die interessant sind an die
frauen gegeben da kommt keiner mehr auf
die idee zu sagen aber das ist auch
nicht mehr gerecht also es ist eben man
die leute werden nicht mehr nach ihren
eigenen fähigkeiten angeguckt sondern
nach dem was sie sind und dann wenn man
eben was ich eine schwarze frau lesbisch
aus
nigeria dann hat man von vornherein
höheren anspruch egal wie man charakter
von einem charakter ist wie man vorher
leistung ist und das ist doch kein
fortschritt das ist deswegen hat das ja
auch an ihrem schlusswort an sie ich
würde gerne von ihnen wissen was
wünschen sie sich denn wir haben jetzt
wir wissen jetzt was einer wohl aber was
wünschen sie sich an schlussmann sendung
also dass sich parteien diesen druck
dieser gruppen nicht
unterwerfen weil ich bin ja aus meiner
fdp ausgetreten nachdem meine fdp die
eigentlich eine liberale partei ist
jemanden als antidiskriminierungs
beauftragte in position gesetzt hat die
selber durch rassistische ausfälle
aufgefallen ist sie hat sehr oft
diskriminierenden tweets vor sich
gelassen und sie hat kurz vor der wahl
ihre komplette tweetie story gelöscht
damit man diese dinge nicht mehr sehen
kann aber das internet vergisst nichts
alle sachen kamen wieder hoch auch ich
hatte mich oft mit ihr gestritten gehabt
wir haben eine antike rimini jungs
beauftragte die sich niemals von den
rechtsextremen grauen wölfen zb
distanziert hat im gegenteil also das
sind dinge die werden hier geduldet von
der politik und ich wünschte mir dass
die musik klingen einfach mal dagegen
angeht ja und soziale kartoffeln
und looser hätte der schluss während
gehören das möchte ich alles wir
beibehalten sie wünschen sich weniger
unterwerfung innerhalb der partei